social media acts like a drug so it  chases this desire for human connection  and serves you an exaggerated version of  it and it serves it to you at this  incredible convenience so that when you  want that feeling you'll pick up your  phone instead of going to find a person  but the thing about this that's really  pernicious is that it doesn't actually  deliver that feeling of connection  because it does not fulfill it you will  continue to be lonely and crave that so  you go back to Facebook more and more  and then over time Barbara this woman  who invented will learn to pick up her  phone and to really chase this feeling  of connection through her phone that she  will never get by Design so that she'll  keep picking it up more and more when  you start to see  that this is something that doesn't just  deliberately by Design addict you like a  drug but that it also changes your  behavior and it changes the way that  your mind works akin to a drug